everyone is Warren and we have some
great news and updates in regards to
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 what James
Gunn directed the first guardians of the
galaxy movie and guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 and was hired to direct a third
one but he was fired so since he's got
fired
everybody's been kind of wondering what
is going on and since he got fired
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 has been
put on hold it was supposed to come out
in 2020 but now it's not so everybody
was worried that guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 would be pushed aside and not
happened for a while or maybe not even
happen at all but I have great news for
you no more need to fear that as we have
found out that guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 is moving forward bring it down
[Music]
Karen Gillan who plays nebula in
guardians of the galaxy and an Avengers
infinity war recently did an interview
with people and in this interview she
addressed guardians of the galaxy vol 3
and here's what she had to say about it
our director won't be with us any longer
but we are excited to continue the
guardians of the galaxy story and keep
delivering to the fans that's the most
important thing I don't have any details
as to win the next guardians film will
come out but there's a script in
existence and then she kind of teases us
by saying I may have had a little teeny
peek but I can't say anything so this is
great news she just confirmed that they
are in fact going to be moving forward
with guardians of the galaxy volume 3
and they even have a script for it no
word on a new director yet but Taika
Waititi did meet with Kevin Feige now
nobody truly knows what this was about
it could be nothing but tyka did direct
thor ragnarok which was a huge success
and was very funny and it also took
place in the cosmos and we know that the
future of the MCU is heading into the
cosmos and who better to lead that than
the guardians of the galaxy
so Tycho has directed both a movie that
is funny much like the guardians of the
galaxy movies and a movie that took
place in the cosmos if it's not tyka
then there are plenty of other great
directors that could take on the
guardians of the galaxy franchise but
the most important thing is that it is
moving forward and we will get guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 in the
not-too-distant future and with that
hopefully we'll get Adam warlock in the
MCU
but that's an entirely different story
so fear no more guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 is happening and it's going to be
happening relatively soon so let me know
how excited you are for guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 in the comments down below
and I'm also giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet if you would like to
enter the giveaway for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]